i'd love to sort of re-explore this as
carlos mancia
oh my god yeah why
why go there again yeah
this i'm willing to do it but
do you like carlos
well first of all i'm friends with joe
and i remember being a fan of i'm
outside this whole world i remember
thinking carlos was funny yeah so just
as a fan i was like oh funny and then uh
i remember this this all this big
controversy uh about him stealing jokes
and
because i'm a fan of yours it's such an
interesting human dynamic and i'm a fan
of friendship and loyalty
and you had a great podcast conversation
with him it was tense it was so tense it
was very tense yeah but it was
interesting
and it it kind of what makes me think of
you talking to your father on that bench
yeah that's essentially what it was um
some of it wasn't getting through but
maybe uh
how do you feel about that
uh whole thing about the guy i mean he
gave you he's a friend he gave you a lot
um
but you're you're also comedian stealing
jokes is no good
but also there's like a
i don't know all the tensions in your
heart about all that whole thing how do
you feel about it
do you forgive them
okay let's just let's go back to
the it's very shakespearean in a very
weird way right because there's some
betrayal there you know i mean there's a
lot of drama when it comes to that
situation um
again also i'm a very loyal guy like
i've had the same manager
since um
in the late 90s
and i've had every
gigantic manager want to sign me even
though my manager is great right she's
in a big company right and there's only
so much she can do
and maybe you know i mean my career
would have been different if i would
have signed with a bigger management i
don't know right but i will never leave
her
you know um i'll never leave my agent
matt you know
the people go well you're at caa that's
amazing the only reason why i'm sca is
because of matt blake you know
so there are certain loyalties that i
have the comedy store
you know i mean i generally play the
comedy store mostly because my loyalties
are with them i don't know if that's a
good trait but it's just the way i am
right i admire that yeah okay so when it
comes to carlos
you know in the early
in the mid 90s is when i met him there
was a doorman at the la jolla comedy
store
he brought me on the road
he introduced me to matt blake my agent
right and he
bought me a car
you know um when i couldn't pay rent
you know and i was really desperate i
could always go to him for money you
know and he helped me out in so many
different ways right so
in
you know i really appreciate that
paulie did the same thing um
so anyway um and then all of a sudden
and i always knew going on the road with
him that
number one i found it odd that he never
had a notebook
you know usually you know
comics
riff with each other and they write
things down
you know i mean me i'll get together
with people and write you know i mean
i'll do a new joke night because i'm
just too scared to try it in front of a
packed room or whatever it might be okay
he never had did that right and he had
hours of material
and you know a lot of it was derivative
of other people's um
he would sometimes
hear a bit
change it to mexican like for instance
if you know if paul mooney had a joke
about black people he would change it
change it a bit but premise wise
it was always
extremely too similar and there are
examples on the internet so you know you
can there's things that you can't really
deny
and so when when that whole thing
happened um
you know it was like the titanic i mean
i was either to sync with carlos
or survive
and i did the worst not the worst thing
but i i made a difficult decision and my
decision was to cut ties
and
you know over the years i've have felt
very guilty about it in in some respects
but um
you know there is always in my mind
i want to help him you know
i want to help him
re-establish some sort of a different
you know
route for him to go in terms of his
career and whatnot and so i had him on
my podcast
and it didn't go the way i wanted it to
go you know i mean i've always believed
if he just fully just
was apologetic and said you know i'm
sorry for stealing in general because we
don't know
specific i mean there's
specifics you know i mean
and i don't want to argue every case you
know so i thought the healthiest thing
to do was like in just in a broad way
listen
i stole i'm so sorry these are the
reasons why
and i'm a different guy now but it just
never happened in that way
and so it's been
difficult
so you you don't think he self-reflected
looking in the mirror about mistakes of
the past at all like do you think he's
aware
i think it's ego
you know i think that he
for one reason or another he um
because there are probably jokes that he
legitimately in his heart know that he
wrote that people are accusing of
stealing right yeah but you know it's
like we don't know
right so it's like
just apologize for all of it right but
he won't he fights for every
you know
every point and you know i just
think that that's not the route and he
i mean he's always going to make money
he's you know he's never going to be
what he should be
which is he's a powerful performer
you know
in terms of laughs
i mean dude i wouldn't i wouldn't want
to follow him he's a crusher
you know so it's like you know it's
really he can act he has all the skill
sets it's just that
to me he went about it in the wrong way
and it's sad to me and uh but i still
always love him and i've always
will thank him for all the help that
he's done so he's still got room in your
heart for him
i room for my heart for a lot of people
man you know hitler
[Laughter]
you